let's play d4
of course anish will be blitzing out
moves now
you asked for it and you get it guys you
get
a match let's play queen c2
takes
okay i'll play with long castle
yeah look at the speed with which he's
playing
he wants to win there's no doubt about
that
can i play b4 i can do that
let me play b4 why not and put my king
on a1
knight c4 okay let's play king to a1
i don't think it was good idea for him
to exchange on c5
[Music]
i'll play queen to a4
maybe i'll first take and then go queen
f4 and put
my rooks on the b file and go for
checkmate
he's taking that pawn really anish you
don't you're not scared
wow he wants to take the pawn on h2
wow amazing
i'll play knight e4 maybe what should i
do
i can just take this pawn first
e4 d5 d6 looks good knight t4
knight d6 is an option i like knight e4
let's put the knight on d6
yeah this looks crushing i just put my
knight on d6
just 24 getting epic content
irish plays for content
rook to h5 i can just play knight d6 no
he has to take i mean he can't really
tolerate the knight on d6
can he
oh he can maybe he'll sacrifice but
the question is when
oh wow he's not at all scared okay let's
play e4
i'll play e5 if required
okay he takes it now takes oh queen
epson he plays queen d4 and it's pinned
interesting
[Music]
wait why are all the squares highlighted
maybe i can play rook c1 threaten to
take on a d7
sorry take on c6 i mean
you can play bishop d7
um replace gh3 okay i'll take it
okay i have some back rank issues
oh queen f74
queen f4 k8
i can play d5
this looks good
[Music]
i can't really take right now
i can take and play e5 or i can play e5
first
e5 queen d5 that does not really work
out
i'll play king to b1 and that's not a
good move
i'll take this queen c6 of course he
does it
queen f1 oh no what should i do
i'll play rupert
oh no he's gonna survive this
oh no i messed up
i messed up and i'm too slow oh no
wait he also messed up i think no it's
okay
oh he's gonna flag me here oh no ah
crap he flagged me there oh
i was too slow i was too slow that's too
slow